ces gendarmes sont missionnés pour
détecter le moindre comportement à
risques pouvant provoquer un incendie
ils sont à la recherche d'un maximum de
visiteurs auxquels prodiguer les bons
conseils
donc je vous rappelle je vous répéterai
toutes les herbes les résineux sont
hyper sec et le moindre la moindre
étincelle peut faire un départ de feu
donc un mégot mal éteint un feu un peu
juste pour faire un barbecue une
flammèche qui ce qui s'envole et c'est
la catastrophe
c'est touristes venus parcourir la route
des vins de bourgogne sont surpris de
l'opération mais la trouve nécessaire le
b à ba de 2,2 du produit premier geste
voilà il faut pas faire de feu on le
sait mais c'est bien que on nous le
rappellent tous avouent aussi bien ça
impressionne mais finalement on est très
satisfait étant donné qu'on n'a rien à
se reprocher certains visiteurs eux sont
moins respectueux la preuve avec ces
débris pour les gendarmes c'est
l'exemple cible de tout ce qu'il ne faut
surtout pas faire c'est le cas typique
d'un feu ont alors qu'ils aient des
panneaux qui sont donc installés en
bordure du chemin on voit que les gens
savent que cet interdit de faire des
feux est pourtant là comme on le
constate c'est quelque chose d'une
ampleur quand même suffisamment
importante et après donc qu'on soit on
va pas s'étonner qu'il ya des feux qui
prennent ici dans sur le plateau depuis
ce récent incendie celui du plateau de
chenôve la brigade effectué pour la
première fois à moto de la prévention la
seconde étape sera celle de la
répression